morning Millennials welcome to the
morning toast it's a beautiful Thursday
morning made even more beautiful by the
fact that I'm here with joey camasta
what's that Cora that's my childhood
oh my god I say we're speaking in other
language no no that's how I say it homie
welcome welcome or Chang welcome to the
show thank you you've been here before
but never with me no I know it's the
first it's a first for everything I'm so
excited to be here we're so excited to
have you we were just talking before the
show a bunch of things that probably
should have waited for the show yeah we
were talking about cam toast and I was
trying to explain it to you and how we
went to camp ababab was like have you
seen MTV's fat camp and you were like no
we've not but I know Tony sparbers
weight-loss camp because I used to beg
my parents when I was a boy just send me
there it's my friend sherry glaze her
went there and it was the tits everyone
like it was like the best thing ever and
I wanted to go under like no just stop
eating you fat [ __ ] it's okay Hershiser
of course welcome so I never got to go
to Tony Silver's weight loss camp but lo
and behold the camp that cam shows host
today is the fat camp
exactly so dreams could come true for
you if you want to come also what's
crazy is one you would have loved it
there and two if you had gone like we
would have met you i camp and like
obviously been fast friends but it's
like the universe made sure that we met
regardless that we were meant to meet
Nate to me about in fact camp brought us
together yes we still had it so were you
guys at the fat camp
yes you guys were you telling your
campers I'm half of us were chunky yeah
and the other half were supportive yes
so and and those they eat that celery
[ __ ] we got you I'm gonna winner I'll
eat it right right beside you yeah you
know it was but as someone who wasn't
there to lose weight like it really did
feel like regular camp yeah we had gone
to regular camp before that it was good
news I think was in the newspaper back
then I mean so you probably weren't like
I'm not so much older than you guys but
it's like when I went it was like an ad
in a newspaper and I just like cut it
out in the back of paper like here it is
the one call the number call the 800
number it's so cute
yeah I love that yeah where is it me
upstate New York
Poconos the Poconos yeah and it's really
not like a bad trip cantos is gonna be
lit on but it's sold out so it sold out
already
yeah but if there's not one room for a
counselor pastor Cora there's a room for
a counselor can i okay we actually need
more counselors
like counselors net she's really just
the greatest counselor Leslie but you
can be the second-greatest counselor
there's always room for that I'm down
obviously if I'm available I would love
to come too
I know how about if you fill my dream of
going to 20 swear words way less camp
because I kind of loophole my parents
are not to pay for it and I can drink so
it's like yeah two birds with one stone
exactly and that's not probably on the
diet though I'll work it off in the lake
you'll work it up and like sometimes
when you drink like you are more active
because of it like you're dancing you're
cheering why they know yeah you're
saying up later and like just using Oh
getting your heart rate up yes ma'am so
we'll make it work for you um anyway see
a great show for you today as all of you
know I am have been tasked with
babysitting Theo while Claudia's got yes
I saw and I just wanted to eat you all
it's going so well so if you're doctors
like dr. Theo yeah dr. Theo fanon
etcetera has taken residence he's saying
he's doing his residency at my residence
right okay got it and it's really great
what's so crazy that what he got a bath
he got about that Claudia from this book
exactly um but when Claudia first got
Theo like Zach my fiancee would not let
him in our house cuz he's like not a dog
person
Oh calm down it's not gonna do anything
no like it cuz he o does shed and you
know he brings in the street Oh on his
paws technically and he's like so
germaphobic so literally the first time
Claudia came over with the oh she like
surprised me she like wasn't I told her
like she really couldn't ring
Impossibles raining and we literally we
had to record a patreon episode and we
sat on my bathroom floor and recorded it
because I wouldn't let Co like out in my
apartment oh my god and to go from that
to gang with us what in progress
five nights and like in my bed blah blah
blah and you know we make it work like I
watch this pause when this act Raquel
he's been really cool and now he's found
his bachelor party he left this morning
so now it's just me and Theo we got a
little privacy Oh last night like he he
allows luxury yeah so that's where Ben
is yes what everybody wise then I watch
it to you right that's why he is with
where'd they go they went to the Bahamas
Oh fun yeah they're gonna have the best
little boys trip little boys have I'm
excited for them I'm excited for me yes
I suppose Jerri public now looking away
your bachelor party oh no was it yours
yes sls yes i started following them and
started liking all the pictures hoping
they'd offered
a free trip but they did not well you
know what maybe just like reach out
shoot your shot
yeah they do a lot of like great
influencer partnerships and we had the
most incredible time of our lives
it was so amazing I was so jealous I was
like watching like everything with the
cabanas the drinks the food like every
time in the hotel is just so pretty yes
it makes you not even look fatty you
look like yes yeah it's like I'm a [ __ ]
but I do it in a fancy area exactly no
but you're going to zoom in again to
take some [ __ ] shots is what you thought
shots yes I'm going to Dominican
Republic to the punch O'Conner
I never been there I just wanted to know
I wanted to swim up bar I like it's
about bar because you know two birds
with one stone you get to swim and like
I want to do that I really don't care as
long as it's sunny out there's a pool
I'm like I can like get belligerent
during the day I love day drinking I'm
old now so it's like you know I can't
make it past like 9:00 p.m. it's like
otherwise it's like I have to take my
boniva I know I have a lot of things on
the on my palette so Jurgen really is
like the loophole for like over yeah cuz
it really like you get more time you
know what I like about it I can get a
while and by the time I'm [ __ ]
blackout I can go home and I can order
rest order seamless and they're still
open if it's not 7:00 in the morning
they're like ivory stealers restaurants
open and then I can like you know get to
bed at a respectable time and like wake
up and then act like I'd like I'm not as
generous exactly you know I'm not waking
up at 8:00 a.m. but like no before noon
at least but like you know I like I
don't go to sleep if I'm going out at
night you don't like go to sleep till
noon so it's like right no day drinking
a drink is where it's at guys I totally
totally agree I hope you have a great
time on your trip of course we're gonna
work you to the bone yes is that okay
yes ma'am okay okay we have the Fast
Five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast okay what's going
on today actually yeah a good amount I'm
not gonna lie because um the Jeff Bezos
of it all are you following this story
no tell me about it Jeff Bezos he's like
owns on Amazon yeah he's the third
richest person in the world or something
I might have made that up but he's worth
I'm sorry he was as a yesterday yeah
this [ __ ] took all the money okay I'm
fast I'm fast fiving to the stories
before they even got here now he's gonna
divorce they got married in 1993 when he
had nothing Amazon was started in 1994
he's worth a hundred and thirty seven
billion dollars ah yes and the big
question is do they have a prenup the
answer is no [ __ ] Amazon CEO Jeff Bezos
and his wife Mackenzie who announced
they are divorcing after 25 years of
marriage did not have a prenuptial
agreement
they will divide their gargantuan
fortune equally according to a report
Bezos 54 who sits at the top of the
Forbes 54 is that rich yes I adult a
billionaire he's the first richest
person he sits at the top of the Forbes
is world billionaires ranking with a
real time worth of 137 points billion
dollars and Mackenzie 48 an
award-winning novelist live in
Washington State a community property
state meaning divorcing couples without
a prenup split assets 5050 according to
CMZ which cited sources with direct
knowledge of their arrangement oh my god
since Amazon was founded a year after
the Bezos is tied the knot Mackenzie
could fetch as much as much as sixty six
billion dollars based on the value of
the company today I am shocked to the
core hmm I mean what was there any foul
play was he cheating like Tiger Woods
uh well yes then that was our regret I
don't feel bad are two of the story is
Jeff Bezos his alleged secretly
relationship revealed hours after
announcing his divorce according to
multiple reports Amazon CEO has been
secretly seeing former good-day alike
Caitlyn Marie Jenner Lauren Sanchez
either one or the other the news of
their alleged relationships comes just
hours after bassist announced that he
and his wife Mackenzie were getting a
divorce after 25 years of marriage so he
was secretly dating this hoe yes well
she's not such a she was also married
she is married to the CEO of WME she's a
thirst trap for sure but she isn't ramen
trap she must have something good below
the belt [ __ ] because she is snatching
all the trophies total all the men was
she hardly see her here she's cute she's
cute that's the rich one
yes that's Jeff that's she looks like a
[ __ ] Rachael Ray yes she does google
her guys no she's very pretty but like
that she I guess when you're in that
circle in that realm of that rich of
people there's only
many thoughts you can go after like you
know are you in trust like you don't
know you don't know like you know who
knows that this hot girl comes I think
you definitely know she's gonna rob you
in the middle of night right he's at I
was like worthy she's like trustworthy
how that can like you know you know
she's knows another billionaire so it's
like she's not the only one right and
she like has proven herself by being
married to the CEO at me like yeah
definitely a treasure trove of Secrets
she loved her husband I think she's
leaving him so the other day she gets
all his money - hmm
so it's like they never never good
happens never and his new wife has the
same amount of money as the other [ __ ]
so it's like he may hit out even he
broke even
right oh my god we have to Google this
but here's the thing Forbes opposed to
this Instagram caption last night
anything was before news of a prenup was
even announced or Glac like once you
know that you're starting to be on
billionaire there's not gonna loophole
you can delete your wife drug like how
Baylor signature game but please this
girl was with him before Amazon like and
he was seen the pictures of him like
before not looking great no and before
he even had money like even skip sadder
and she was with him and she was with
him while he was just like some nerd in
his garage like doing an e-commerce site
for books but you son started out as yes
so like good for her I'm excited for her
yeah she and like she deserves a man
like he'll be absolutely fine there's
there's enough to go around yeah there's
not I don't think you'd spend that money
like consciously even if you are buying
islands like you can't spend all that
money in your lifetime you're 54 you
have like 40 years probably just like
you spend all this but what's so crazy
it's like when like rich people get
divorce and like they get huge
settlements but like what they'll say is
it's not even enough to have maintain
the lifestyle that they once had you
know it's not but so I wonder if 66
billion will be enough I wonder how much
I need to continue the lifestyle I'm
living not much okay but listen to this
after 25 years of marriage Jeff and his
wife Mackenzie have announced their
divorce as the richest person in the
world worth an estimated one point one
hundred and thirty seven point 1 billion
dollars it is not clear yet how the
divorce will impact his net worth or
whether will affect his stake in Amazon
the e-commerce giant he founded in 1994
Bezos owns 16 16 percent of the business
which comprises more than 95 percent of
his fortune if Mackenzie Bezos does
indeed receive half of her husband's
assets she would be worth
and 68 billion dollars making her the
fifth richest person in the world
look yeah and even if she receives a one
percent payout which isn't gonna happen
because now we know they didn't have a
prenup but even if they had had a prenup
she just got 1% that would constitute
one of the largest divorce settlements
in history absolutely that would be like
1.5 billion dollars 1% of it because he
has hundreds with millet billions
[ __ ] so it's really it's really
wild out here for the Bezos clan I love
rich people yeah this is like super
interesting I wonder who she's gonna
date next I don't know
he'll own us it could be what is he
doing what is he doin Tesla oh right in
the world is he some of the rapper
Grimes what is happening with that
they're like dating she's on the rapper
she's like indie I don't know
but everyone's like some no not me not
her but it's like like Azealia Banks yes
she is talking about Elon Musk about
what's happening yes okay because Elon
Musk is skating Grimes who are living
together I'm assuming you know what is
he what is he is he like is he young is
he like a young hip guy he's young I
don't know about the hip part but he's
pretty cute he used to date Amber Heard
yes
and so like she really you know gave him
street cred I met her she's really
pretty I met her so then sadly they
broke up I think he like it took him a
while to get over it but then he started
dating grinds who was a young chef phase
oh Sh he's 54 I think he's in his 50s
young hip hop hooray hookers well like
that's the thing about grind she's not
your average run-of-the-mill hip hopper
a hooker right exactly hip hop all right
okay I'm sorry
Elon Musk is 47 years old saying you
know what I mean it's not me I mean not
47 not yet yeah so he's eating Grimes
and Grimes invited Azealia Banks into
the home mmm where apparently for a
dinner party yes we're like just friends
you know like coming up somebody and I
guess they were like all doing drugs and
Elon was crazy and then she tweeted
about it
no I don't think so no not like that
that's what it was I was wondering why I
was - seeing Elon Musk's name and with
like with like female rappers like yes I
was very confused it was a confusing
time and it's like at the same time that
he's like making a submarine to rescue
the Taiki boys his summary
he tried to make one but and that was
weird too I don't know why would you if
I was that rich like I'm I would do some
[ __ ] up crazy [ __ ] like builds like
the funniest things like I'd like make
like full-on like stores like like joke
stores like you know you mean just like
was this real really well
we will continue to update you have the
basis family fortune yes because it's
real and everyone is really so taken by
the story yeah I mean it's insane I mean
it's like when you have the richest man
in the world and something like that not
having uh cuz you figure like everyone
who's like wealthy but people just don't
he wasn't like wealthy beforehand so
it's like you don't really think about
that and it's too late now to be like
[ __ ] can you sign this when you started
knowing that things are blowing up right
he also had an affair on her so she
deserves yes she yeah I think cheating
is worse than murder yeah yeah because
you have to live and with the single if
you get killed you just like dead you
have to deal with the pain of it when
you get cheated on it's like you're like
murdered every day that's really sad
yeah good morning when you've been
murdered every day okay this next story
is a little old Golden Globes news but
Jamie Curtis is resurfacing it obviously
you saw Jamie Lee Curtis yes yes the
Fiji water bottle girl yes she's blowing
up she's lying she's got like a hundred
thousand followers this week or more
than that she should had like thirty and
now she has two hundred like twenty
seven she's a model she's wiggling or
Delray yeah well she is a model like
she's with Wilhemina so you couldn't
have happened to a more worthy person I
was more concerned I'm such a weirdo
I was watching I was like oh my god I
wonder how they poked the holes in the
top of the thing did he use a drill
notice and the plastic bits will get in
there I think how do the feet remake
specialty caps so the straw can be
placed in between I had a whole thought
process like an hour thinking about it
and then over those glass straws they
look empty definitely well they we know
they weren't possibly probably paper
yeah no they were clear they look like
glass oh that's kind of fancy yeah so I
was what if they were glass and probably
when it comes to the caps they probably
unscrew the top and then like use a hole
puncher or something some sort of it and
then screw it back on take the shot okay
I was working a phase a drill it was get
all the plastic bits in there and like
be jagged
I was like wondering how they did I want
to do for my guess when they arrived
that's kind of you
yeah um so Jamie Lee Curtis took to
Instagram she posted a picture of her
with the photobombing Fiji water bottle
girl yes she said so my husband who
doesn't look a lot of show business news
sites just mentioned and I was on the
CNN website
I specifically moved away from the
blatant promotions by Fiji MOA where
young women with their trees filled with
their wares stood near a designated
camera I knew why there was a
photographer poised there and I moved
away as I said out loud that I didn't
want to be doing advertising for either
clearly this angle shows that although
their angle shows that I moved from her
being behind me and yet from the side it
still happens the sponsors of events
need to get permission from people when
they get them to take their pictures
next to products comment she just
worried that though she's gonna lose
your contract avea [ __ ] yoghurt
that's exactly what's happening so she
was she was not regular that day but
your panties were in a bunch she was a
little constipated you need to eat
another yogurt Jamie Lee and calm down
by the way her dress looked like a
vagina in the front like a slip oh it
did but like a diamond the jacket of a
jazz Oh vagina yes yeah why'd you think
about her look overall people were like
she was gray hair now and that was a
little off-putting it was like white
white yeah it was it looks very like
like sci-fi to me yes very cute though
you know she was born with two genitals
no she's a hermaphrodite like she was
born of the penis and a vagina and then
she decided she wanted to have a vagina
google it it's true do you know that yes
it's all the news I'm old that's true I
know these things okay well I don't
think she had like a full vagina or
peanut she like had like it was like you
know girl pick your poison and they were
like okay and she went that one that's
probably her voice is so deep
she's a third sexes person she's a wife
third sexted person okay
didn't know that yeah thanks to me new
everyday good morning okay but I do
understand where she's coming from in
terms of like yeah people get paid
really millions of dollars like Jennifer
Aniston her contract with SmartWater is
probably right upwards of ten million
dollars and like if she's in that
picture like that picture is worth 10
million dollars yes
step out yeah and it was also like the
thirst of it all yeah it's almost like
having a separate repeat with like you
know like
in the back of it right they sign up for
that you know right for any of that
exactly and like when people walk the
carpet they'll choose not to do that
because they're not endorsing products
because if you paid a built probably
billion dollars to be on that red carpet
with the water bottles but not to the
people watch the people now but like
they should have paid people to go and
take pictures with that girl yes you
know exactly not I mean just blatantly
put her in the background with smart
marketing on there yeah everything like
that on the red carpet before but it was
it was aggressive except I did watch the
CMAs once and I saw two drunk girls
pursing vodka in people's faces those
are beautiful they are really pretty
yeah I will talk about later I'm
obsessed with that but you guys have to
do that I mean you what's you don't know
which I want to see amazing about her
and Claudia Murray ASHRAE what's her
middle name Geller
go astray yes but you are a country
music fan and that's not something that
you would expect no it's like it came
right mother my mother loved country
music and she would like listen to all
the time and I just got like into it and
I just love it like it's like I can't
listen anything else like every day
although I really is the mood for
everything I listen to some Dan and Jay
this morning since young last night know
who are some of your favorite acts I
definitely love the Combs is my number
one right now um a wild card came Brown
is one of my one of my good favorites I
love him
Luke Canon shade you like that symlink
Rascal Flatts yeah I thought last night
wedding stones from Rascal Flatts
it's gonna be I'm here you know perfect
you could have sent any song and it
would've yeah that what it was my oh my
favorite songs
um I'm drawing a blank I feel like I'm
gonna on stage right now
this always happens to me I listen to
Sam hunt yes love Sam huh well Mike's
his girlfriend's a jealous [ __ ] really
yes she's just you know anyone looking
at her man so she's that she's forcing
him not to you had that on good
authority or this is your my shorty Dana
told me and she's obsessed with him she
has a picture opposed she's a married
woman of three children and she has a
picture of ripped out magazine like from
teen Bob on her headboard okay Sam huh
good she says pretty
great you see me like so obsessed with
Sam hunt like literally rounds out and
now because I don't hear from him yeah
I'm not but I would have been by here I
actually loved him like so much I got
he's my number one I used to watch
videos of him like his music isn't throw
my phone because I couldn't deal with
how hot he was totally it was like oh my
god I can't but now he's m.i.a yeah Wow
you guys wait what's the other ones I
like sadly over rattly Gilbert yes he's
great
Dirk's bet no no no Brett Eldredge yes
is frien Luke Bryan snobby yes like
Jason Aldean luke bryan blake shelton
like they don't really just Lance Dustin
Lynch
I love Dustin Lynch sorry Chris Young do
you know yes Mitch I'm gonna now okay
now it's coming it's all I mean that's
everything guys get into country music
it'll change your life you're gonna like
what you hear you're gonna like what you
hear yeah okay there's nothing better
than a drainage ring in a pool with
country music
nothing it's my number one favorite
things to do in the world there's
nothing better than drinking at camp
around a bonfire
music I'm coming yeah okay by the end of
the show like bags are packed yes okay
next story that we've been talking about
a lot but I also do want to get your
your thoughts on it yes after Kevin Hart
debacle Oscars will forge ahead without
a host the Oscars are poised to embark
on one of the most radical reinventions
in the awards shows along history for
the first time in nearly three decades
they don't upset anyone the biggest
night of movies plans to go without a
host individuals with knowledge of the
plans to a variety producers will select
a crop of a listers to introduce various
segments instead of relying on one
marquee name to kick things off in a
monologue filled with Trump zingers said
the insiders the producers and the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences the group behind the Oscars are
scrambling to line up top talent needed
to carry the telecast which is just six
weeks from airing live on February 24th
from Hollywood's Dolby theatre
hand-wringing at the academy has been
palpable as it stands no new offers are
out nor are any expected to be mean to a
single potential host to fill the void
left by Kevin Hart who dropped out
within hours of being selected when he
refused to apologize for his past
homophobic remarks that had resurfaced
on Twitter
barring an eleventh-hour pivot by the
Academy in the event that a superstar
host materializes the show producers are
moving forward with the broadcast that
will focus on stories
it's and play up a high-profile year for
music and film thanks to likely nominees
Lady Gaga Dolly Parton Kendrick Lamar
Lamar I guess he wrote a song for a
movie oh I'm assuming um first of all
once they did not reach out to me have
they reached out to you know so so
clearly they're dragging their feet up
yeah because there's two great options
right here right and there's something
like they could definitely obviously go
you know with superstar talent and have
the best show of their library and
choose people like us or you know they
could keep a traditional there are so
many comedians out there and I'm sure
most big-name comedians don't want to do
it at this point because one it's been
tainted - it's a thankless job yeah
three I'm sure the pays [ __ ] before like
everyone hates you afterwards regardless
of your performance yes because yeah no
one can ever do good I mean hard him I
think it's also a taboo area because
like now it's like been tainted with
this like story line of you know now if
they hire whoever they hire never
everyone's gonna be like oh you only do
this because of this because of that and
this one and they'll dig some [ __ ] up
about the other one it's like it's not a
witch-hunt [ __ ] we just need someone so
now who's [ __ ] winning the awards
[ __ ] totally and like whoever it is
next like that person is basically
saying I'm perfect because I have no you
know past indiscretions or things that
you can be mad at me about and so here I
am standing on yeah right each think
you're asking to be picked apart you're
asking for people to go through your
Twitter whatever as a confirmed
homosexual I would like to go on the
record and say I am not offended by when
people make comic jokes
I think it's funny that's again you have
to make fun of life when people attack
comedians like all those people that
like you say one joke and then like
that's what comedians do you make fun of
things that are serious to make it light
that's what your job is comedian and
it's not like and his jokes were were
homophobic but they weren't
mean-spirited and so I think you know I
just think anyone I think people should
be able to have freedom of speech is a
thing and I'm not offended by anything I
love I love controversy and I love you
know off-putting jokes that's what makes
things happy that's so refreshing I mean
I hate when people are attacked for you
know being a comedian like making light
of things that are funny do you think it
makes a difference that the tweets were
10 years ago do you think that makes it
any I do I think I think now I mean cuz
now with a political climate like you
can't like like blinks the right way and
people are offended it's like
I think that's another huge thing now it
becomes like you know you dig things up
like feeding back then look at
television back then I mean like people
were saying like you know you people
were referring to trans women as
[ __ ] and like all this things like
I'm like I'm on major like primetime TV
and now in this you know now that is
completely we all know that's like
completely like off the limits and like
you know just back then it was a
different time right and they have been
everywhere you know there was just so
socially now it's never socially
accepted acceptable to be racist or like
to be you know a homophobe but it's you
know it was like that's the climate that
was that then yeah so I think nowadays
it's everything so super sensitive
that's why it's so shocking to be like
oh my god we were happy but that's the
time I think that's why it was there was
so many that's where everyone's digging
all this things up cuz that's just how
it was back then totally had a song
called let's get [ __ ] in here yeah
and now like Kim Kardashian can't say
that in a live stream no she'll get
arrested right it's like and she's like
she didn't she had apologized so really
times that [ __ ] I got trouble yeah
oh I just said it sorry guys also how do
you think about the way Kevin what do
you think by the way Kevin Hart has
handled the situation since I think it's
right because he he's just as fed up as
everyone else is about how everyone's
sensitive house Oprah's sensitive and
the world is right now I think it's good
that he does like they don't back down
to it it's like it's getting out of hand
how super super sensitive everyone is
like girl you're a human being and
you're an adult get over it if you're if
you're worried your whole life you're
gonna worry about something some mean
think someone set you on the playground
girl you have a lot bigger problems then
than that so get it together everyone
grow the [ __ ] up that's how I feel do
you wish I think I just addressed the
public yeah do you wish that he would
host the Oscars at this point are you
glad no I think it's no a big fan of his
work I think he's funny yeah I think um
I think he's short so he's made a joke
about him right and it's like he can
joke about you and you can joke about
him yeah exactly
no I think he's I think he is funny I
just I think now it's like no it's like
you talk [ __ ] about me I'm not coming
here now and like you know totally I
just think I we'll see how it goes
without a host I think that um I love
that whoo let's talk about hosts that we
think it would be a good fit I love the
James Corden's
he did it once Grammys
it was met was it yeah yeah it was nice
is funny
shall I know I love James Corden and I
was disappointed but like because it's
just so it's like the bar is so high
when you're a comedian like you have to
you know it's at but then you also can't
be mean see the funniest jokes about
time but then also like Jimmy's Oliver
John I don't know but he like is
annoying and he deputy I think he I'll
have sex with him but he I could see her
give me annoying someone I was thinking
of the other day that would that I
thought would be really good but now
obviously dr. Theodore of course you
know if they only called on dr. Thea for
Theodore for Taemin I think he would
really bring everyone together yeah but
they're not in tune like that to that
sure that anyways they're gonna have why
don't they have like a hologram of
someone that be some interactive like
millennial [ __ ] or instead of having no
one like why don't they have just a
bunch of people no they're gonna have a
bunch of people announce specific
categories but like who's gonna open the
show who's gonna like you know bring us
where's Oprah got her ass in there you
should have like a legit host you know
yeah wasn't Oprah wanna do it she'd be
good I don't know like what about Diane
Sawyer
okay livery drummer totally do you know
Judy I wonder what I referred her as
Caitlyn Marie Jenner I want a shout-out
her show and she did her she had a
ceremony around the pool like her
rebirth and her birthday ceremony and no
one knew this at the time she was like
there was priest or the shaman over the
[ __ ] was like transitioning her goes and
and who do we take this name my sweet my
steer child and she goes Caitlyn Marie
Jenner and we no one knew that there was
gonna be a middle name and I was like oh
my god it was like the best day of my
life oh so now you refer to her as Haley
I tell everyone Marie Jenner that's
every anyone steal Marie Jenner
Theo Marie Jenner honestly I see it yeah
he's and we'll talk about so free or
later you know have a girlfriend
yes I'm obsessed with them they're cute
I'm obsessed it's like everything I want
just want to live there it's like and
like see all the ongoings what's going
on do you know show when it was on I
think it yes of course because like
what's so crazy is everyone was you know
so invested in her story yes and then a
daughter Bebelle Joe no one watched it
like no I was invested in watch number
obsessed yeah I was never on since I
think after a show it became like you
know you see this is like a horse and
pony show it's like no not it's like of
course the transition is what it is but
I think just like the whole now I want
to be like this like like sexy reality
star story like that's what was tired
about it right and also like if you
wanted to be a sexy reality star like
you could have like yeah ten years I'm
the sexiest reality show of all time
yes I'm just obsessed with everything
Caitlyn she's like it's just like my
it's my happy place come down for supper
that's nice oh my god I forgot throw hug
that really is like keeping up with her
and her story and you know what she's up
to now yes because now you can just
relate it all back to us because oh yeah
I don't have to find out yeah I know if
everything just felt yeah just make sure
you stay tuned with me I'll tell you
everything I want with Sophia and Chris
Caitlyn exciting and they were at the
holiday party right sure we're good for
them yes they got to invite everyone got
the invite even Sophia Richie got the
invite Aspen yeah she I think in like to
Mexico I think everyone's like now that
they're like our billionaires I don't
really care about like a petty shitty
but I think when you come in like that
level of success like you don't really
need to care about anything anymore
also Scott and Sophia happen together
for over a year like that is legit as
hell yeah you know I think they're a
really good match and you know if
Kourtney wants to be a one big family
then she has to embrace Sophia and
that's fine yeah that you think she
secretly wants to go Scott again like no
she was a controller Hansen she had so
many opportunities to be with Scott she
wants to control the situation I think
that's what's the problem she wants like
have like him dangling to always like
want her yeah and he did for so long and
she didn't and she didn't move on it you
know shit-or-get-off-the-pot
true that and he got off the pot bye
girl bye
okay next story a little uh like biz
news that might help you guys and also
we were talking about this and it refers
to you know it's my idea you know I was
I was saying I imposed and I was seeing
it was it's a bill collector is
everything okay
I hope so
well actually I might have you a
solution for you one fee for Netflix
Amazon and Hulu digital TV reeben
billing gains momentum' oh cord cutting
I was trying it
hi I'm Matt someone I'm a cord cutter
technically but I'm someone who goes
around and like evangelize is about cord
cutting right because like you're a
vegan right it's not um it's not the
easiest thing to do no it's not a
seamless especially for a pop culture
princess like yourself right it's not a
seamless transition and the thing about
it is it requires you to have someone's
cable log someone who pays for cable in
order for you to get every app and get
access to everything so it's like we
still need people who are paying for
cable that's why I'm not gonna tell
those people to cut their course because
we need to use those those accounts yes
we do we need them very much observers
increasingly believe it is inevitable
that the era of bundled streamers is
near as households tire of paying an
average of 107 dollars a month for cable
I pay more well I have two big TVs and
their DVR now both ones oh you get like
the premium do you pay for like star
versus show diamond I said set it up I
think I have no boyfriend or family so
it's like let me just that's all about
cord cutting is I have an app for
everything but it's like you don't just
go on like the MTV app and just start
like watching something gonna make you
log it in no we're like just press the
button to say choose what you want to
watch where it's like and I use you to
TV which has about maybe 40 50 channels
and once I'm done scrolling them how do
I usually do think on my Roku like or my
like am I saying yes act like Hulu or
Netflix I don't need that another app I
don't need that no but only if you were
to cut your kids are premium content on
there I can't get on are there anywhere
else on the youtube TV yes technically
like the ariana grande dangerous woman
diaries were YouTube's premium I which I
got for free is a YouTube TV member oh
you pay for YouTube TV
yes but much less than you pay for cable
yeah yeah yeah yeah you do pay for you
where do you watch The Bachelor you to
TV they have ABC oh sorry only networks
that they don't have that I've been
suffering from our MTV um
CW they're the Food Network hallmark I
believe they have the Food Network I
love the Food Network oh I know Garden
is like my real mom oh the Barefoot
Contessa yes
as the great tea bundling of cable grows
courtesy of skinny digital offerings
where consumers get a few dozen channels
thanks sling TV from Dish Network
instead of several hundred Roku On
January 2nd took a step towards bundling
streamers the maker of Smart TV devices
led by CEO Anthony wood said its
customers can now choose from 25
offerings including showtime stars and
epics alongside lesser-known streaming
entities like noggin drop out and
tastemade and pay for them out on all I
love tastemade and you can pay for it on
a single bill financial terms weren't
disclosed but observers estimate that
Roku is taking up to an ongoing 20
percent commission on each subscriber it
and list weight cuz I want to do this
how do we is it open for business
i Roku I don't know it sounds like I
don't like it doesn't sound like an open
for business yet but I have I pay for
Hulu I pay for Netflix I pay for Spotify
I'm crying I'm surprised so much stuff
on Amazon crying I have but that's comes
with your Prime membership doesn't it
yes but you pay for Prime membership but
that's not the one of the yearly fee or
do I pay every month to do I don't know
I start quick it ever you don't even
know how much video kind of a free on
Amazon Prime I love Amazon Prime right
so between all of those then you would
just need a youtube CD or a sling and
then I can cord cut and then you can
cord cut and then you get the HBO app
you get the Showtime app but I can't
give you I don't need to DVR because
every time they are on YouTube TV you're
crazy not crabby that's that's crazy
yeah it's not as bad as you think so if
you you know if the bills are coming out
too hard yeah so something to think
about
come on YouTube TV okay our fifth and
final story is regarding surviving
r.kelly latest developments he is under
investigation in Georgia he was evicted
from his Chicago studio where a lot of
the music studio yes his should have a
music studio where he had like a
bedrooms and like girls are living he's
such crazy he's such a creep he had a
bed like in the studio well I would not
go for that I would like it better
everywhere I go just a nap and um sleep
off a Pinot Grigio hangover for
different reasons for sure
no but he was evicted from that studio
and after a deafening silence from Lady
Gaga who has worked with him like
recently on that song do what you want
with my body that was our Kelly yes and
like if you think about Valera
and it came out in 2013 I love that song
it really was we could just replace her
with Christina Aguilera like they've
done that that thing right but let it's
like the the message behind it and Jojo
are Kelly is on it makes it and being
her and us an Oscar nominee right she's
nominated yet frosters I did ask her
nominations I heard about it um so I
want to read to her statement she's a
lady Marie Gaga that she released last
night after everyone was really waiting
to hear from her because a lot of stars
and artists were included in the
surviving art Kelly documentary where
they you know kind of this is a series I
thought was a gonna show its I don't
think a movie but it's off its episodes
lifetime lifetime app you can watch it I
do that I'm gonna course John Legend is
in it chance the rapper talks about how
he regrets working with our Kelly but
our Kelly was actually in the film he's
actually and there to talking about his
thing about him not not to him so he's
not actually talking about it no it's
just usually testimonies or anything no
oh I thought he was there sitting there
being like doing like confessionals like
yeah this is how I felt with this and
listen oh no it's all of the women the
many women that he abused during his
career it's really it's harrowing and
like you think that you know you think
you know like are Kelly discussing you
know like child pornography pee in the
mouth but you have no idea how deep it
goes so he's on children my sex with
them how was he not in jail by now it's
like a harem of girls and women that he
like manipulates and keeps as like sex
slave I mean if we have all this
information there's no reason he should
be on the streets at this point right so
now we I mean that's been the thing it's
like we've had all this information for
so long they when he wasn't convicted of
child pornography it's like he felt
untouchable he was filming the
photography yeah he films everything and
he's having sex with underage girls
therefore its child pornography in
addition he's a documentary filmmaker
yes technically but the documentary film
you need to see is surviving are Kelly
yes now Lady Gaga has finally spoken she
said I stand behind these women 1,000%
believe them and know they are
Brannen pain and feel strongly that
their voices should be heard and taken
seriously what I am hearing about the
allegations against our Kelly is
absolutely horrifying and indefensible
as a victim of sexual assault myself I
made both the song and video for do what
you want at a dark time in my life my
intention was to create something
extremely defiant and provocative
because I was angry and still hadn't
processed the trauma that had when did
she get sexually harassed um
I think like while she was coming up in
the business couch like a casting couch
situation yes this song is called quote
do what you want with my body I think
it's clear how explicitly twisted my
thinking was at that time if I could go
back and have a talk with my younger
self I tell her to go through the
therapy IDEs
I have since then so that I could
understand the confused post-traumatic
state that I was in or if therapy was
not available to me or anyone in my
situation to seek help and speak as
openly and honestly as possible about
what we've been through I can't go back
but I can go forward and continue to
support women men and all people of all
sexual identities and of all races who
are victims of sexual assault I've
demonstrated over all your bases [ __ ]
I've said I've demonstrated my stance on
this issue and others many times
throughout my career this is true I
share this is not I shared this not to
make excuses for myself but to explain
till it happens to you you don't know
how it feels but I do know how I feel
now I intend to remove the song off of
iTunes and other streaming platforms and
will not be working with him again I'm
sorry for both for my poor judgement
when I was young and for not speaking
out I made her write I love you I just
want to say I'm sexual harassment like
when you get to my age and wait I would
actually be honored to be sexually
harassed by someone it's like you mean
like no one's trying to have sex with me
for money or for a job or for a
promotion I would I would be honored but
this isn't sexual harassment it's no
that's rape I'm talking about her her
part when she was trying to get all up
in the biz no I don't know I'll sleep
with anyone for a job it's like I don't
know I don't know her exact story and
she like I think was like once like what
examples are but she has been very vocal
about it she did write that song till it
happens to you for the documentary like
a yes that's that's something else yeah
so that's why it was really people
really wanted to hear from her because
her working like doing this song with
our Kelly really wasn't in line with all
of the other stuff that she said and the
work that she's put out so after this
document came out she felt that she
other needs to come out with a public
statement yes well I I support that I
support
- and I I mean it's not for me to like
accept her apology but he seems like a
sick [ __ ]
he seems like a sick hashtag sick and
there were a lot of artists who who
worked with him and and maybe knew or
didn't know where it didn't believe at
the time what was going on because
honestly it's I'm bewildered how he's
not in the prison right now
well now he's under investigation since
this has come out because all these
girls are saying he touched me
and then the problem is that the girls
that he has like in captivity now or so
cops every activity where in his like
various homes are so brainwashed by him
that they won't he's a bottom J James
Manson James dent was named it wasn't
Charles Manson but Charles Manson's
murderer now Hamer but he still have
that culture he kept these women like
brainwash them oh Jenny and he just died
in prison get a swastika on his head
yeah
trash trash so I mean that the people
that are with him now like in this cult
are so brainwashed by him that they that
they don't leave and money is gone now
so I mean I don't know so I wouldn't be
laying there getting peed on if he had
no money say what am I saying there for
because like you're mentally like
intimidated by him and and just like
just get up and I do they are they lock
down lock of Asia you would need to
remember that song he wrote stuck in the
closet or locked in the closet that's
was real [ __ ] about those women locked
in his closet problem and that's what
you watch exactly they say he was hiding
all this in plain sight and all of his
lyrics he never he never even pretended
like he wasn't this sort of person but
except for like the I believe I can what
are you doing like is he
he obviously has troubled in the brain
but he was he's easy
he's just why he's women like staying
with him because thank you for their
phrase weeks later Lee well your I'll
kill your mother as he intimidates and
he threatens them and he has completely
brainwash them into thinking that like
he's the only person that loves him that
they have like he separated them from
their families their friends they have
no one else like they are these like
strippers that from the streets like who
are these people they're just like young
girls who either like looked up to him
we're we're fans of his or we're hoping
that he would help them like with their
careers and he just like and they're
dead and he meets them when they're very
young so this just starts so early and
like hard to kids hide your wife and
hide your husband because i'll Kelly's
right but I would have you okay watch it
because I think you'll feel a little bit
differently it's very it's it's um sumit
churning was that it was that a term yes
your stomach is turning turning yes
makes me very nervous
yeah no it's it's tough stuff I was
watching episode six last night how the
is there six for that but the sixth one
was one the hour long there yes some
might be a little more than at the fire
my seamless accountant make a day of it
no you well I thing you won't be hungry
after I watched them peeing on people
you don't watch I you just hear about it
you hear about it yeah so now these
girls that went to the show are they
safe now
no he still has women but the witches
that were on the side of the women that
were on the show telling everyone he
peed up those women yes you're safe
unless he's like being they were in his
like cult for years how they get out is
to get out like they just either their
families like one I don't want to spoil
anything for you or they really like
something happen and they just muster up
like the purse should run out the door
yeah
when the pizza man comes sure I don't
know if they get pizza he also starts in
that's not nice at least feed them so
you should well I don't want to live
there or get peed on by him somebody
else maybe but not him no one else yeah
anyways hopefully justice continues to
be served for him and that everything
he's ever had or ever known is taken
away from him yeah uh let's get into
some lighter news yes oh my god this is
a dark and twisted episode total I mean
it's been like this all week is even
talking about a somber time know every
episode we end it's like oh that now I'm
depressed
um because you are a resident expert on
all things New Jersey yeah sure
make sure two big things that are
happening in the Jersey Shore actually a
lot of things are happening but yeah
that we care about most
Ronnie got hit by an ashtray that's not
one of them okay one of them is Kwest
force yes what's going on what can you
tell us well I can tell you that
there's all this like speculation about
her like China's take the kid away the
kids away from the husband Roger that's
on the case at all Jenny like says it's
very clear he's a fabulous father and he
never would want to see the children
away from him but that's the last thing
she would want to do you know she she
she just simply is seeking a divorce I
mean she said you know people fall out
of love I guess and I think that's what
it was there's no foul play no one
cheated no one but it seems like it's
contentious as hell like him in like a
cop car
yeah you know the camera the nest camera
yeah yeah that's it seems that I mean
it's like what are your thoughts on
Roger I've always liked him I think it
was always nice to me and very nice a
great daddy I think he's funny I thought
he was hot he's dead I think he's hot I
just think that she I think they you
know they want one of different things
and they you know was you know she was
looking for someone more supportive I
think I think she know he was in a
supportive her career and what she's
wanting you know for herself and I think
you know whatever people the divorced
for but it really is no foul play but
now it's like I think it's in the media
is becoming this big circus because
simply she just wanted to you know make
sure that her kids were you know safe
and I think they're both like I have
this idea in their head that they like
no one wants to look like loser kids go
for it right but there's no reason for
either them to lose their kids there's
like nothing and the court would ever
take their children away from each other
I think it's just I think it's confusing
and scary time and like I don't know I
just think it's like you know I feel for
both of them
more Jenni style though well they
announced their separation like a while
ago and then they were trying to make it
work do you think that they there's a
chance that they would get back together
after this I don't know I just I don't I
do I mean I because since there is no
like no real like no real Wilin out or
anything like in like in and forgivable
unforgivable going on who knows I mean I
think that there's definitely a still
you know especially have children I
think people you know it's
it'll stick together for the kids you
know but I don't know I think you know I
don't really know I don't think that
like anything horrible is happening like
they're like hate each other
so there is a chance they can rekindle
the thing you find yourself in the back
of
cop car what was he doing the cop gran
see them like she she called the police
and they get out yeah and then he would
started recording videos like to tell
his side of the story
oh yes and then there was that that
shadiness with the UM with the
ex-boyfriend the extortion yes that was
wild
so what happened was the ex boyfriend
Tom went I guess Roger was like
contacting people to to testify against
her it's like a bad mom or something
like that
so so she went here I guess he contacted
this one guy Tom and said whatever son
Tom contacts Jenny said I'm about twenty
five thousand dollars like okay that's
really good hundred thousand but or I'm
telling everyone like you know that
you're a bad mom or something and then
she's like okay and then it gets like
she got involved the cops there anyway
and then she's like okay I'll give you
the money and then meet me at the
Starbucks and she went to Starbucks to
meet him and then he was locked up oh my
god yeah wild well I loved her I like
Roger and I hope they can see their way
out of this and maybe they shouldn't be
together
yeah I think so separately they're both
I mean especially Gentry closest friends
so yes of course she's my ho my name is
but um yeah I can you know I hope
everything works out for those two and
their kids are so sweet so they look so
cute you know let's talk about hitch ooh
a ssin yeah so see you at the wedding
just meal of the sitch hitch and Laura
Lawrence missus snitch yes I was there
I'm Laura Marie Jenner Laura Marie
Jenner was there it was a fad it was a
stunning us affair it was um in New
Jersey at this place I forget what it's
called and when is he going to jail this
month that's so sad is everyone so sad
about it yes how long is he gonna go for
eight months I think it's such a such a
charge we got to say goodbye not me I
mean not us we had a Jersey Shore family
dinner like Christmas dinner this is
like right before Christmas so I got to
see him them but like I think it's very
saddening because he's like he's like
the least the last person you would want
to have to go through that this is so
genuine sweet and like he was never now
yeah I mean he was never a dick to me
but it's like I can see what you know
like hope my Lee happen he's been sober
for like almost three years now I think
and yeah it's just it's
you know he's he's accepting it and he's
gonna be an adult about it and he's very
strong spiritually and mentally yeah I
think it's I think it'll be fine it's
just sad that you just got married and
I'm just like go like Liam yeah very he
just like wants to get it over with you
know right like just get in there cuz he
can turn himself in like up until a
certain probably yeah so like I would
kind of just go and be like let's start
this sooner sooner than later
yeah I get home make a baby maybe get a
couple months of summer like I'd rather
be in jail in the winter I don't know
where now Timothy I don't know where
he'd see me probably in New York or New
Jersey somewhere yeah do you think he'll
be with Joe Giudice
I hope so they have similar crimes
they're both based in New Jersey yes I
don't know maybe they could strike up a
friendship we could get a spinoff yes
the Real Housewives of Jersey Shore yes
he's actually writing a book on his way
Joe yeah no no hitch said she's reading
a book when he's away but it's like he
doesn't know what it's gonna be about
yet because um he's like yeah he's gonna
live his life he treats I live his truth
actually that would be an interesting
books I'm sure he'll also expand on what
was going on like when he was in his
heyday yeah and that's really like so
interesting yeah I'm a cultural lever
level to that and Theresa Marie Giudice
she wrote a book when she was the way
Teresa Giudice she did do you read any
of these celebrity tales I read that
once when I was she I want to buy it so
I was like that person that sat in the
Barnes & Noble I'm the one who like
hunts for a chair for hours like at like
oh like I'm prayer like stalking my prey
Wow I was like he's one cherub out on
the Upper East Side one that I really
like so what how do you sell these bars
and Noble like going out of business are
they all of them but like a lot border
is gone you know bookstores aren't what
they used to know why they're not
meeting Jeff Bezos in Amazon for that
yeah and remember when the coconuts is
around did you guys have coconuts
where'd you grow up in the city uh Long
Island on the city what's coconut
coconuts was like it was like Sam Goody
murders your bus just buy CDs like in
records
oh I don't even know cuz they don't have
that when you're young holy dude I'm 26
soon we did have CDs but I don't recall
yeah well they used to be stores you can
buy them coconuts coconuts is one oh
that was on a rich man show in Union New
Jersey that's right where hail from but
yeah like a there understand were CD
stores anymore
like you'd go there to buy music like
there be a whole like the music section
and target that would be a whole [ __ ]
story yeah and there was like tons of
them and so that's that's doesn't happen
out we never would know we came and
think about look and I don't have a
chair to sit in
how was Teresa's book any highlights yes
she would she found likes to make girls
like in the prison to blow her hair out
it's like do her nails I said that was
fun and then there was like lesbians
like having sex next to her in the bed
when she first got there and she was
like mortified chirping noises
interesting I I usually do pick up a
sled town that's not the one about this
so she's like this uh yes I think it is
the same book stronger something like
stronger Sinuhe could add something
something
okay and the last thing is you went to
the premiere party for Lindsay Lohan's
Beach Club
yeah show I haven't seen it yet please
tell us about I didn't watch the show
but I did watch her mother spilled
drinks everywhere tells about Martina
Marie okay so I got it was the Lindsay
Lohan premiere it was this week and it's
on every I don't know what season what
day was that party on I don't know but
Monday it was on Tuesday what's on
Tuesdays okay it's on Tuesdays at 8:00
on MTV crane and check your local
listings and it's basically Lindsay
Lohan's trying to be Lisa Vanderpump
that's what I've heard
yeah so it's basically she's like I'm a
boss [ __ ] and she was wearing the video
shows I'm boss [ __ ] like that and her
like the lips were like weird anyway so
she has his shows of this like beach
club in Mykonos so I'm really hungover
guys Beach Club Thank You nose and she's
like so the stories about all the people
that work there like the waiters and
waitresses and bartenders and [ __ ] all
hooking up so it's just like Vanderpump
rules but with a messy Lindsay Lohan in
town yeah and and a mikonos [ __ ]
so she I got to the party and she was
there she was um there's a two sections
of the party and there was like you know
the VIP section I'm like for the
commoners and I would say CLE add it as
in the chimera list big mistake yeah so
I call I had to call my agent and I took
all my friends we like I'm in the wrong
area then when I was escorted back to
the right area
I'm she was there perched on a little
bench with all her friends chain-smoking
inside which I love
how did she look gorgeous Grecian a
Grecian white dress it was like I was
like - here it looks like when I was
like Greek goddess dresses there wasn't
long was like here and I made it had
like one shoulder and her I was like you
know like this and like that red lip and
then she had a red coat on when she left
but she would know she was very Cupid
she was here hanging me on this side and
then on this side and it was like you
know very tame and like sitting there
like drinking cocktails smoking talking
[ __ ] with all like he's like gay guys
around her and then I'm the polar
obsolete this is the room where Lynne
she's not inside and then this side
that's where the real hot mess
trainwreck was that was ginamarie Lohan
and she had like 60 of her friends they
ought fur coats on they were wiling out
screaming standing up knocking
everything over every time I went looked
over there there was a janitor in front
of ginamarie Lohan with a mop and they
were like this they were like like every
time in front of her it was like this
and they're like mopping things up
she was limbs everywhere screaming
wiling out knocking drinks over and I
took initiative for I said I took a
photo with her I did not post it yet cuz
I'm saving it for a special time but she
I was talking to her when she left I
asked for a photo and she could not even
she even know where she was as you can
see an expression in her eyes oh you
look good thank you
can you see this guy's we could post it
to the toast ID if you're gonna post yes
I J of course I'll send this over but
yes she was like sloshed hot mess I mean
she could post up I mean she wasn't
vomiting or [ __ ] herself but she was
definitely drunk but I had a good time
and [ __ ] that was a real surreal story
she looks young I think she has Benjamin
Button disease because she looks exactly
the same age as Lindsay does that's good
Jamie maybe like Lindsay just looks old
and that's it's it's a combination of
both but they definitely look like they
could be the same age ya know she looks
good in that picture it like skin wise
ya know she looked he she was stunning
she was I mean I'm gonna say stunning
but she was gorgeous
pretty put together gorgeous hair
extensions kinda nice coat dressed
beautifully
nothing's wrong I mean she's just having
living her best life if my daughter had
a hit reality show on a major Network I
would be excited to chew on getting
drunk at her premiere that's true look
like three drinks or the
I said it's like she's been out of work
for so long like Dina has you know not
even reassure you're married if she's in
the dating spectrum you know I don't
keep up with her with their personal
life i barely keep up with the father's
the mess right there both i don't know
who's messier mmm
who's the messiest but it's like all
messy and you would thing like okay
we're getting like a second chance third
chance fourth chance right think maybe
relax
oh right do you know but you also have
to stay true to yourself so as long as
she had a good time he's very on branch
what do I care it's very on branch our
lives you refuse to take pictures of
that everyone my friend Vinnie Vinnie
Marie Gladney no he was there he was
there and Lyndsey refused to take a
picture with him she'd not refuse he
asked her she said he's like how you
know let's get a picture something that
she'll say oh yeah yeah maybe in a
little bit or something - and she's like
brush it off and like was very like but
did she know who he was yes
grid you know so she was not taking any
photographs maybe she was chained
smoking indoors I don't know I can't
believe they still let you do that in
some places like that her joy tries to
light a cigarette and then one of the
exact we're like people at MTV as a
friend to me she they get that out and
she's like she bursted out of my hands
we're trying to control her and not add
to it well he's doing I can do it I
guess not yeah well thank you for
joining oh my God thank you for having
usually informative yes he was also one
watching have inside last name anything
else tab yeah I didn't watch it yet I
haven't either but I'm so excited yes
it's a perfect duo but they she was also
supposed to be on Gailey pop yesterday
and I watched that's in LA yeah and they
said that like she cancelled because she
wasn't feeling well so well chefs in LA
how are they gonna do put a puppet a
lady called in calling she didn't even
do it she's hired she's a lot on her
plate yeah maybe she was tired from the
party yeah anyways thank you so much for
can everyone follow you thank you ended
yes follow me on instagram at instagram
on and scream manages the at instagram
account yes mr. P 79 mas ter P 79 you're
gonna like what you see you are its
premium content you can always follow me
at Jackie O problems I haven't asked you
at home to take care of so I've got to
keep it short you can follow us pop with
no job we're serving a premium content
all weekend
tomorrow we're joined by the bride
Olivia oh and we're gonna have all ask
her
all of your bride related Olivia Marie
ASHRAE possession
jeno Shapiro and then we will also be
joined by Josh from birch events design
who's gonna be I saw that you know that
you were there at this point was because
I'm now doing my wedding and so I am
actually gonna use his opportunity
selfishly music talk about your weather
questions I'll to come back I know
there's like guide you coach after your
wedding
sure okay yeah anyways thank you guys
for tuning in we will see you tomorrow
have a wonderful day
you